- The last time I ate a
stick of unsalted butter,
I feel like I was like 10 and I realized
that this is not the
way to live your life.
(upbeat music)
- When I was a kid, I
used to drink A1 sauce
straight from the bottle.
No one ever knew that
this is something I did
until I was at the
refrigerator with the bottle
up to my lips and my mom caught me.
She threw away the A1 sauce
and never bought it again.
And it burns a little bit going down,
I remember that a little bit.
I don't think I'll go back to
doing this regularly at all.
But it's still good.
One more for the road.
- I can't remember the last time I ate
Arby's sauce out of a packet.
I think in middle school I
tried to be a little less weird
so probably age 11 or 12.
Yeah, it was pretty bad.
It would be worth it if I went to Arby's
and got another sandwich
and put the sauce on it.
But yeah, no, I'm not
feeling great about that.
- The last time I ate a
stick of unsalted butter,
I feel like I was like 10 and I realized
that this is not the
way to live your life.
In Indian culture, we have
this one god, Krishna,
and he eats butter,
and all my comic books,
they would talk about him
grabbing the fresh butter
that was just churned
from the milk of cows.
So I went to my fridge, tried some butter,
and I was like, "That is the stuff."
It tastes like creamy nothing.
I do not like this.
Maybe it's different if
it's fresh from a cow,
but this is like the fridge
of Costco or something.
- I used to eat mashed avocados in milk
with condensed milk and ice.
My mom actually did this for
me when I was growing up.
I don't know if it's like
a specific Filipino thing
or something she just liked to do,
but I just grew to love it.
See, that's really good, that's
family recipe right there.
What I would say to my old self is,
"You did it right with this."
- I used to pack a bag of
salt in a clear Ziploc bag
and just bring it to
school and people thought
I was doing drugs, but it's
actually just a bag of salt.
The reason why I stopped is because
my blood pressure was getting super high.
I was always dehydrated.
This feels so good, but at the same time,
I'm like, "What the heck am I doing?"
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I would never do that again now,
it's like strictly in the past.
Hey Mom, I'm sorry, I used to eat salt.
I know that you always
told me that's not good,
too bad, I already did it.
- I used to eat a ton
of gross shit as a kid,
but my ultimate favorite is tomato sauce
or ketchup on white rice.
I think I discovered it by chance one day
'cause I like to dip most
things in tomato sauce,
but then when I put the rice
with it, I was just blown away.
I think we all have weird
things that we enjoy,
I'm sure there are better-tasting
things in the world,
technically, but this is just
really comforting for me.
I crave this as an adult almost every day.
It's the sad truth.
- Oh my gosh, this feels so nostalgic.